conservationists are trying to stop
Nestle from pumping more water from a
well in rural Michigan Nestle got a
permit last month to increase production
from the well in Everett Michigan the
company says it is environmentally
sustainable but residents claim pumping
more water will further damage the
area's resources Nestle's water brands
including Poland spring ice mountain and
Arrowhead brought in four and a half
billion dollars in sales last year
Adriana Diaz went to Michigan to visit
the Nestle well and factory it's like a
ocean of water bottle absolutely
this Nestle plant in North West Michigan
spits out water at a dizzying pace
bottles are filled labeled and packed in
mere minutes so this is our new 80,000
square foot expansion so last year we we
invested about 37 million dollars in
addition to expanding the plant Nestle
is planning to pump more water from this
rural whoa but the quiet here belies the
controversy you can live without oil and
you can live without gold but you can't
live without water
Peggy case and John McLean are with
Michigan citizens for water conservation
in January the group sent a letter to
state regulators blaming Nestle for
significant loss of surface waters and
aquatic life in two creeks near the well
the levels are down and almost
impossible to find trout in what used to
be two cold water trout streams I had
water rationing in Vietnam I don't like
being without water in 2016 Nestle
applied for a permit to pump an
additional 150 gallons per minute at
white pine springs the state received
more than 80,000 comments from citizens
about the plan only 57 supported it
Nestle's request failed the state's
initial environmental impact test but
after a lengthy review it received
approval last month we have three
sources in Michigan for ice mountain
water
Arlene Anderson Vincent is a natural
resource manager at Nestle what we see
is is a very very stable water levels
over 17 year period of record which
tells you that this is sustainable and
we're not negatively impacting the
environment Nestle contractors
demonstrated how they monitor water
levels 33.5 there
they say that their little dip sticks
and their little monitor somehow tell a
story they don't so do you think they're
lying Nestle is a corporation with a PR
plan they have their story we have ours
why do you believe that it won't
adversely affect the environment if you
increase the amount that you pump Nestle
Waters employs a group of natural
resource managers as myself our job is
to ensure that the withdrawal is
sustainable run of muddy walk this is
like quicksand oh yeah
Anderson Vincent showed us where the
groundwater in question emerges into
strings do you have a sense of what
level would be unsustainable is it a
thousand gallons per minute I don't
we've looked at you know 500 600 700
gallons a minute and really felt it was
you know 400 gallons was extremely
protective of the ecosystem here so
that's a conservative number for you
it's conservative number people are so
angry Rebecca Warren is a michigan state
senator it feels like a company's
profits are being put a head of the
needs of the citizens of Michigan and a
resource that you know if you grew up in
this area people love our Great Lakes
Nestle water says they've invested about
270 million dollars in Michigan creating
765 jobs and more than 160 million
dollars in economic activity so do you
think all the backlash has been unfair
people are very passionate about water
and so are we and we respect that
passion Nestle does not own this water
this water belongs to the people and the
ecosystem for CBS this morning Adriana
Diaz Stanwood Michigan I understand why
that's a huge controversy yes since the
issues have not been fixed in Flint no
and I like what John McLean said I don't
want to be without water and nobody does
hopefully they'll work that out